what's up people
what a weird movie we're talking about
today
not a bad movie it's not it's actually
really entertaining but i forgot how
strange this movie was maybe that's kind
of why i feel like a lot of people don't
really talk about this anymore and i had
actually sort of forgotten about it i'm
pretty sure that i saw this one in the
theater back when it came out in 1994. i
saw it i mean yeah i'm almost positive
that i saw this in the theater and i
remember being like hey that was pretty
good but then i kind of forgot about it
but then like a couple weeks ago i saw
that hulu had added it i think it's on
tubey as well if you want to watch it on
there but and i was like oh yeah [ __ ] i
remember that we should rewatch that for
the show because it's like i remember
that being pretty good but like i said i
forgot what a strange
genre mix-up it is
it's got a hook all right yeah and the
hook in this is
werewolf
movie for adults
yeah they're trying to make it
palatable
to people in their 40s and 50s
and yuppies
if you ask me uh because they're trying
to make it as classy as possible as
intellectual kind of as possible
and it's
it's beautiful movie really where it's
shot the locations and everything just
uh
there's kind of like uh intrigue in it
and uh jack nicholson slowly becoming a
uh
a werewolf
i mean you know it happens it's a cool
idea
not my choice i would say you know i
mean so it can be a little bit long or
it seems to be kind of slow in certain
spots
they're trying to build up tension which
i guess works
but i like fast and fun better when it
comes to monster movies
it's like a sophisticated monster movie
and the thing about this one too is that
i think if you go into it because i saw
i watched the trailer like before we
recorded this and i was like well the
trailer absolutely makes it seem like a
horror movie it is a werewolf movie but
i don't think i'd call it a horror movie
no it's sort it has some horror movie
aspects to it drama but it's more a
drama that also happens to have a
werewolf in it and the werewolf is
almost kind of like used i don't want to
say it's used as a metaphor it is kind
of he is an actual werewolf it's not
like he's imagining it or anything but
it is kind of used as a metaphor for him
like kind of getting his groove back
like because he's going through like a
mid-life crisis just like going on hrt
that's what that's what and i knew you
would say that too because well yeah
that's like essentially what it is
because
he's kind of like a dude that's sort of
like a little bit of a pushover at the
beginning and like when he starts
turning into a werewolf it starts making
him more like assertive and he actually
starts doing better in his life so
there's that kind of thing too even
though he does absolutely turn into a
werewolf kind of yeah so uh so yeah as i
said wolf came out in 1994 listen to the
[ __ ] this this movie cost 70 million
dollars to make isn't that crazy i don't
think they would do that nowadays like a
drama and i was thinking about this just
now i was like
um a big studio would not pay 70 million
dollars even in today's money
to make an adult and not adult in the
sense of porn but like a more like
mature like people you know geared
toward people like middle-aged people
that had a werewolf in it they would not
spend 70 million dollars on that like
this kind of like genre crossing type
thing like an indie movie might do it
and i've seen some that did but a big
studio wouldn't although this did make
money i think it ended up making 130
million 140 million something like that
when it came out trying to do is they
were trying to do
for
old school monster movies they were
trying to do for that
what richard daughter did for
uh with superman one for uh
superhero movies they were trying to
bring back
high-end monster movies
yeah okay
before this time before these times i
guess you could say even though this is
much much after superman one
superheroes and monster movies were
[ __ ] kids that was for [ __ ] kids
yeah it was garbage all right so they're
trying to elevate those
and uh superheroes got elevated you know
mcu and all that
yeah um and they've been trying to do
that with the with monsters movies you
know like universal monsters forever
it's been failing
well essentially i mean when this movie
came out in 1994
there i think people forget and i might
have brought this up when we were
talking about the brendan fraser mummy
movies which were another kind of uh you
know that was also sort of like a little
bit later where they were trying to re
redo the like universal monsters but
right around this time they were trying
to do that too because if you guys
remember
they did uh francis ford coppola's
dracula yeah they did uh kenneth branagh
did uh dr did a frankenstein and also
and i had totally forgotten about this
one until i was looking into it there
was a movie with julia roberts called
mary riley which was essentially jekyll
and hyde um and but it was from her
point of view like i think she would
like worked in their household so she
was like telling it from their stories
there was that one i don't think it did
very well but uh when somebody mentioned
it i was like oh yeah so they did
actually try to do and this really does
kind of harken back
like i said i don't i wouldn't call it a
horror movie but it does kind of harken
back to
the original uh universal monster movies
in the sense that it's like character
based yeah um this one isn't set it's
not folkloric necessarily because it's
set in the modern day in new york city
like in the big publishing industry and
stuff like that but then they inject
uh you know a werewolf into it but it's
a lot more like character driven it's
more like a like a drama like a drama
but with some comedy and romance in it
but it's also a werewolf it's a straight
up werewolf movie yeah it's classic
werewolf movie in many ways
yeah it just updated it yeah and they
didn't like i said so just don't go into
it thinking it's going to be like a a
traditional more cheap like teenage uh
monster movie type thing because it's
really not like that it's funny that you
were saying about like superhero and
stuff because i was reading a couple
there's a really a couple really funny
write-ups about this movie one was on
den of geek and one was on collider and
i think it was den of geek that said
essentially what this movie is is a
superhero origin story except for
middle-aged people
you know what i mean and i was like yeah
that pretty much calls it right there uh
and whoever wrote the piece on collider
who i think is also a writer for cracked
but he said even back in 1994 the median
uh target age for this movie was 47
years ago i figured yeah yeah because it
was i mean well he was making a joke but
it's not really a joke because it's kind
of true that's kind of true right and
i instantly picked up on what they're
talking about
is um steroid use testosterone use is
exactly what they're talking about well
it's a guy that's having a midlife
crisis
like i said getting his groove and all
of a sudden he said he's got something
in his blood that's making him come back
and
it's a werewolf bite
but that's not and then his hair starts
growing his body hair starts growing
back and stuff and he and the heritage
and he looks a little bit younger starts
becoming more aggressive he's
intimidating younger man and [ __ ] and uh
i'm going like whoever wrote this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] around with
testosterone well a woman wrote it so
elaine wrote it
she did a research then
yeah maybe she knew some dude that was
doing that because hrt is not new people
have been doing it since the 50s it's
just that it was a small tiny segment of
dudes that knew about it
but yeah i mean the thing about this
movie there's so much you can see why
probably this is targeted more toward
like an older audience or that why they
made that joke even back in the 90s
because
listen to like all the [ __ ]
oscar-winning [ __ ] behind this so you
had like jack nicholson in the main role
he had michelle pfeiffer yeah uh you got
james spader who i totally forgotten was
in this movie he's great
uh kate neligan she's not in it all that
much richard jenkins christopher plummer
for christ's sake david hyde pierce all
kind of [ __ ] the score was done by ennio
morricone for christ's sake and it was
directed by mike nichols for [ __ ] sake
who you know very famous who's afraid of
virginia woolf the graduate probably his
best-known one catch-22 silkwood the
bird cage charlie wilson's war dude has
a [ __ ] ton of oscars he also made day of
the dolphin but you know
everybody [ __ ] up every now and then
but uh yeah so this was and it was
written as i said by elaine may who was
his longtime writer collaborator partner
and so a lot of the funny [ __ ] i kind of
feel like comes from her because this is
almost kind of like a very droll
office intrigue movie with a werewolf in
it yeah you know maybe there's a lot of
good touches to it though it did i liked
it a lot
when when
the first part of the movie i'm watching
goes boy jack looks pretty bad in this
yeah you know but there's a reason yeah
i didn't realize that they were
kind of doing that on purpose it was
very subtle yeah you know
um that they they kind of told him
you're like you're gonna be a little
schlubby he said jack's looking kind of
bad but then by the time [ __ ] that
werewolf blood starts kicking in it's
like hrt he's [ __ ] verily again we
carries himself his face and just he
changed and there's no prosthetics it's
just the way they shot him and i guess
probably a little bit of makeup and how
he carried himself his attitude he just
he seemed a lot younger even though he
wasn't he didn't look younger yeah he
didn't look younger he seemed younger
though well that's probably like i said
i kind of feel like maybe like the
scenes at the beginning they're kind of
like hey why don't you walk a little
slouched over or they might like deepen
some of the wrinkles on his face make
him a little fatter made him a little
fatter like made his hair look thinner
like [ __ ] like that so then like when he
changed later on it's not real dramatic
you just but you can still tell that
just looks a lot better walking a lot
straighter and it's like he has more
hair it looks like yeah
he looks like he's i think his hair
might have been a little bit darker a
little bit thicker even though he's
still bald kind of like you know he's
beating ball in the front it's just it's
not as prominent and [ __ ] was getting
spiky and he had more facial hair when
he turned straight werewolf he had his
beard would come in and then go away
that was pretty weird they don't that's
one thing i got to say that i did like
about it
they didn't really use any
werewolf prosthetics
no and rick baker did the [ __ ] on this
he did american werewolf in london
obviously and he worked on the howling
as well
so you would think that this would be
kind of like a special effects
extravaganza but it's very restrained
real restraint like kind of like the
original wolf man in a way just yeah
yeah strange than that actually
uh he just would do things like
couldn't he run on all fours when he had
to he could jump
he could i don't really think he i mean
he did kind of it was mostly just kind
of like jumping around like running fast
yeah um you know he did like jump high
walls and stuff and i could kill dudes
with his bare hands
yeah he could kill young men with his
bare hands you just see it in shadow
which i like that
because it probably wouldn't look that
credible if they actually shot it
it was more credible when you saw that
guy's
shadow of him killing that guy
underneath that bridge for [ __ ] with
it yeah and which i liked it he could
talk as a as a werewolf too which i
liked that yeah he didn't completely
wolf out he was still like 90 percent
guy yeah you know what i mean he just
kind of looked wolfy with gold eyes yeah
he would say [ __ ] kind of like uh kind
of like dr jekyll would say or mr hyde
would say you know
yeah this might have this kind of works
too it's just more like a jekyll and
hyde story although you know it's more
werewolf because like i said it's the
moon and it's just like night time and
blah blah but
um you know it's the same kind of thing
and they kind of go into
you know him maybe like this is this
will be good because it's making him
like i said a lot more assertive and
he's not like letting people walk all
over him
anymore i don't give a [ __ ] what you all
say i like [ __ ] i like [ __ ]
russell crowe as jack duck jackal
yeah that moment movie i was i was
intrigued i was like oh i want a whole
movie that
i kind of wish they had made that movie
yeah instead of the mummy movie yeah
that would have been a lot more
interesting i kind of there's not enough
jacqueline hyde movies i kind of feel
like
crow could [ __ ] do it great when he
slowly just he's in the middle in
mid-sentence just slowly start
turning in to [ __ ] hide and i'm like
listening and i'm going right along with
him yeah yeah
hell yeah yeah let's do that yeah
i didn't realize that he was turning but
i just was sounding good yeah yeah okay
yeah the one thing about this and like
like you said it's probably good that
they didn't go like the whole straight
up horror action movie route there is
like a big kind of if you want to call
it like a boss fight like at the end
yeah um which is not shot super well no
but like i said mike nichols he's more
of like a drama guy
um so he's not really an action director
so i mean he did fine like for what it
was and for the time and for the time
but there was like a little bit of like
cheesy slo-mo in there and like stuff
like that but it's not it's not terrible
but it's on par with the superman boss
fight that's true yeah pretty much like
that it is kind of like which when you
look at the old donner superman you know
that
fun but not
nowhere near what you could do today
yeah nowhere near so what happens in
this movie you might be asking so jack
nicholson plays he's like the senior
editor right of like a big publishing
house in new york city uh he's
presumably been doing it for a really
long time at the very beginning of the
movie he's coming back from a business
trip i think and he's in vermont or some
[ __ ] like that and it's like out in the
snow and he hits
a wolf
and he thinks the wolf is dead so he
goes over there and is like what the
[ __ ] and he's like poking it and then it
comes out and bites him and then for a
long time there's like no wolfery going
on in the movie it's just kind of like
establishing he goes back to his job
he's got a wife they haven't had sex in
a while there's that whole thing going
on and then he's working at this
publishing house and this publishing
house has just gotten taken over by
christopher plummer's character who's
like some billionaire
and even though
uh
will his his which is jack nelson's
character's name he's pretty sure that
he's gonna get fired like a lot of them
are gonna get fired because this the the
company that's taking over they're just
like well we just want [ __ ] that's gonna
like sell zillions of copies we don't
give a [ __ ] if the book is good or not
type of thing
so
uh so then there's james spader's
character
who
is pretending to be uh will's protege
and his friend and everything like that
but since it's james spader you know
pretty much that he's just gonna be like
this weaselly backstabbing [ __ ] which
is indeed what he turns out to be also
turns out that he's banging uh will's
wife too on this lie
so all of that's going on there's like
all this office politics um
you know jack nicholson ends up getting
fired
and
then he meets the daughter of the guy
that took over the company who was
michelle pfeiffer now i will say
i know that two of these were together
uh
together in witches of eastwick which is
another one we should do because i
actually really liked that movie
although the book was better
but
uh but yeah so
one thing about it is that i get that
they were doing the whole uh jack
nicholson's having a midlife crisis then
he gets bit by a wolf and then like he's
like hey this werewolf ray thing isn't
so bad after all because it's like
making me look younger and more virile
and i can jump over [ __ ] and all this
other stuff and oh by the way sometimes
i kill people but okay well you know and
women were interested in him all of a
sudden yeah so i mean it is a move on
michelle pfeiffer didn't work until that
until that [ __ ] wolf blood started
kicking in well now he yeah he already
had been bitten at that point because he
was still spooking the horses and stuff
but at first she was just he didn't know
yeah it kicked in remember now she is
considerably younger than him
so
i think i think at the time of this
filming she was 20 years old younger
okay i thought uh so it is a little
weird but you know what i mean
all the time that's what i'm saying so
i'm just saying it is a little weird but
between rich people it works out it was
between rich people and i actually
really like her character like i just
she
because i feel like she just gets to be
i don't know i have a feel i don't know
her but i just kind of feel like her
character in this movie is kind of like
what she's probably like in real life
you know what i mean i don't know why i
get that impression but she just comes
across as very like naturalistic
so they kind of start a little romance
because like i said his wife is bonking
the
james spader and he finds out about it
and like kicks her out and uh you know
starts crushing this uh this younger
chick and also he starts like i said
there's not a lot of wolfery going on
for like a significant portion of the
movie it's suspense they're trying to
and then yeah but he just starts doing
[ __ ] like um like he gets like super
hearing and like super smell
and
yeah his senses get really heightened
and then he decides hey i'm not gonna
like take this
getting fired thing lying down and he
decides he's gonna not only get back at
james spader for being a backbiting
little [ __ ]
but who took his job and is banging his
wife uh but he's like i'm gonna get my
[ __ ] job back and i'm gonna be a
senior editor and he starts like
dropping his nuts like i'm in there
going i'm gonna leave and i'm going to
take all the authors with me i'm going
to start
marking his territory and achieving
dominance inside the pack
becomes dominant over his boss
yeah by getting getting [ __ ] leverage
on him and uh
it's a it's a lesson in a lot of a lot
of [ __ ] what happens to you in life
has to do with how you play your cards
he started playing his cards right and
actually using the strength that he had
he had these strengths he just wasn't
using them yeah okay i kind of well i
kind of feel like that's one slight
criticism i could give the movie is that
jack nicholson is jack nicholson i mean
whatever movie he's in he always comes
across as a little bit of a lunatic yeah
so
it's it'll yeah in a good way so i don't
really buy it like at the beginning of
the movie he's kind of supposed to be
like this meek like pushover type of
dude you don't quite buy that because
you know that he's not really like that
like but he seems to play everything so
he plays plays everything very subtle
you would think because jack nicholson
actually was had been trying to get this
movie made because he really wanted to
play a werewolf apparently uh for a
really long time until you know for many
years prior to it getting made and so
you would think that he's like yeah i
want to play a werewolf so i can just
like wolf the [ __ ] out and chew all the
scenery and spit it back out but he
doesn't do that he plays it actually
really really low key and like
restrained which is kind of an
interesting choice according to brian um
uh jack nicholson has a real good
reputation in hollywood
for being generous and uh
amiable real friendly real alpha
kind of guy well see that's sick that's
what i'm saying i i was talking to him
so he seems like he comes across as he
seems to me like he'd be a dick
and he's like no he's got a real good
reputation he's got a real good
reputation for being real cool
but see that's the thing because he has
and like i said i don't know him
personally i'm just saying like from his
movie roles he always comes across he
never
struck me as being like a meek person or
a person that would let people push him
around so i think that's like slightly
not as believable at the beginning of
the movie when he's kind of supposed to
be a character like that they don't
overplay it
but he's just somebody that's sort of
like he's not really meek he's more like
complacent yeah he's kind of he's like
middle-aged he's like you know he's
gotten to a point where he's just kind
of like not progressing anymore
right it's just kind of more like that
yeah he's stagnant he's not rapping yeah
rather than just being like oh yes mate
it's he's not like obsequious it's more
kind of like he's just like yeah
whatever yeah well that's what i'm
saying he's not competitive yeah he's
not in the game the younger guys were in
the game more competitive and we're out
running him
yeah that's right because woman and
everything i mean especially james
spader yeah that's what we're talking
about yeah i mean just that guy
i love james spader and i just reviewed
uh a movie that he was in in 1988 called
jack's back where he actually played a
little bit against type
he kind of played like a nice guy but
usually james bader i'm sure he's a
perfectly nice person in real life but
he was just really scarily good at
playing like really
playing pricks he was just really good
at playing arrogant douchey yuppy pricks
he was just so good at that and he plays
that in this like to a t
you know what i mean he is just kind of
like he just flares those big ass
nostrils and the thing about this one
too this the character that he plays in
this it has like kind of a little bit of
another dimension because he's also
really backstabbing like he pretends at
first like hey i'm your best friend and
oh my gosh i can't believe he got fired
that's such a bummer or blah blah and
like all this time he had been
you know kind of going behind the scenes
and like getting his job and like
[ __ ] his wife and all this other
stuff while pretending to be all genuine
and [ __ ] so i kind of really like his
character in this and it's so he kind of
becomes like the main antagonist
uh you know as the movie goes on so it's
almost kind of like a weird like i said
it's like office politics drama
it's funny too but it's more like witty
funny
you know it's more like droll funny it's
not like zany funny
and
but then there's like a werewolf in it
it's not super gory it's not
really the only kind of big werewolf
like i said boss fight you get there is
the one scene where he attacks those
three he's like in the park at night and
then like those three thugs like come up
and try to like take his money or
whatever and then he attacks them but
like you said it's just in shadow it's
implied and then you don't really find
out what happened until later like he's
in the bathroom and he goes like that
and he pulls out like a couple of like
severed fingers and he's like oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did i do last night
because he can't remember yeah um
because he gets into the thing where am
i going out at night and killing people
and then he gets like all [ __ ] upset
about it and it starts like chaining
himself to radiators and whatnot yeah
but uh it's a good movie
it's uh
not typical
yeah for a monster movie at all
the
the werewolf
element of the story is kind of just the
superficial element of
of the story it has a deeper meaning
okay
the deeper the deeper message is
basically to men if you ask me and it's
about aging
that it's a morality tale about that
what the what the story is telling you
is that you get older as a man the game
changes but you can but you can still be
in the game you just to play the cards
differently
um also there is even there is
definitely
a a a subliminal hrt message or hormone
replacement therapy message in there
that you don't have to age normally
that you can put something in your blood
that will make you make you keep your
edge for a lot longer that's that is
it comes out basically says that
the even goes to a dude who kind of like
a
witch doctor kind of guy who explains to
him what's going on he has to get bitten
so he can have it he said no he says
okay i respect your decision
so
they're talking about hormone hormone
replacement in 94 they knew about it
although the interesting thing about
that is that when he goes and sees that
guy uh he's played by um puri yeah and
uh that guy i don't think he's not like
a witch doctor he's like a folklorist or
some kind of thing like that like he
studies that type of thing he
understands legends and [ __ ] yeah and so
he goes to see that guy but the
interesting thing about the mythology of
the werewolf in this movie
uh it's i don't even know if it's
implied or if they state this outright
you don't have to have been bitten by a
werewolf to become a werewolf yeah um
it's like i'm sure it helps but
basically he says something like if you
have the passion of the werewolf then
you can just become one without having
have so you can just if you're like
wolfy enough inside yeah like if you
have that spirit in you already then you
don't need to have been bitten by a
world if you will just become one if you
want it better i guess though
he was bitten yeah he was too and yeah
so but like i said just to be bitten
yeah so it's just saying even that guy
who is kind of like the [ __ ] joseph
campbell of the story even he wanted it
he wanted something in his blood because
he was dying he was like really really
old he was dying too but something in
his blood would have it would have
helped him
there was and he also said something
that is it's not about damnation or
morality says that wolves aren't
don't worry about morality
it's just
it's just nature
it's well natural what he said was that
you know the spirit of the wolf is not
good or bad but if you're a good man it
is
then it'll be good if you're an evil man
then yeah it'll be bad right and [ __ ]
that's hrt that's what he's talking
about but see the interesting thing
about it like i said you know the men in
this get bit by wolves or in james
spader's case
gets bit by uh jack nicholson
but the implication at the end with
michelle pfeiffer is that she didn't
have to get bit because she already had
the wolf spirit inside which is kind of
like established with her character i'm
guessing
uh because she didn't get bit at any
point i don't think
uh so i think that she just became one
because i think that was what they were
implying that women don't need
testosterone well see i think you're i
think you're reading too much
yeah i think well because i know you're
very testosterone that's all you kind of
like to think about now that's what
they're saying so yeah i know i get that
metaphor but i i think you're taking it
like way too far like way too literally
all right i don't think they were
literally saying that in the movie
because they did bring up you don't have
to have been bitten by a werewolf like
it doesn't have to be get into your
blood you just have to have that spirit
within you so i think it's not even so
much like hrt it was just kind of like
you know
whether you're a man or a woman like
finding your uh finding your
assertiveness is what it was don't let
yourself get complacent even if you're
old um so you don't really need to even
like posit yeah that it's something you
inject or something like that they're
just saying joke and complacent as you
get older you know you still have a lot
of life ahead of you just get out there
and like drop your nuts and like do do
your [ __ ] you know what i mean get your
confidence back that's kind of basically
what the the general message of it is
too like i said so i think that's why
like michelle pfeiffer it's
essentially becoming a werewolf without
having to be bitten they were just signs
well she already had that spirit within
her that's
if that's what the message was then the
message is saying that it's
that that it's more than one factor then
it's attitude
and what's in your blood yeah okay yeah
it could be both
and yeah that's
it's a holistic approach is what they're
talking about yeah pretty much and i
kind of liked the and i mean that's not
crazy like because i have read some
folklore
before um where it said you don't have
to have been bit by a werewolf because
there used to be there's some of the
some of the werewolf
legends have like all sorts of [ __ ] that
has to happen before you become a
werewolf but some legends have it's like
you know if you're just like a really
really bad person like a serial killer
then you'll become one or something like
that so you don't necessarily have to
have been like cursed by a werewolf or
bit by a wolf vampire story vampire
stories and werewolf stories if you look
if you go back far enough
they're about serial killers pretty much
they'd find dead women and stuff mauled
up and they would say oh a human
couldn't have done this well you know
a vampire did it or a werewolf did it
they even caught a guy i think was in
the 5th 1400s or 1300s they caught him
out in the woods living with his sister
and the children that they had together
and he was a damn serial killer he was
jumping on farm girls and raping and
eating them
and he believed he was a werewolf
yeah i've been wanting to do a show
about that guy actually i think i put it
in the poll a couple times but he didn't
we thought he was so because that's a
pretty famous and the people thought he
was too
so things like that have been going on
for a long time i believe well yeah
that's where the legends came from they
don't it's not like people don't
actually turn into wolves but those
legends do come from somewhere yeah you
know what i mean
um interestingly a couple trivial facts
about this is that the michelle pfeiffer
role was originally gonna go to
sharon stone uh but she turned it down
yeah i'm glad if i forgot it yeah i
always liked michelle pfeiffer to be
honest with you i even like her in
greece too for heaven's sakes she sings
in that
okay she's a cute woman she yeah she's
actually quite a beautiful woman yeah um
and also you would point it out the
in this movie the interior of the
publishing house where jack nicholson's
character works um is a very distinctive
building
and we were like yeah that's that
building's in like a [ __ ] ton of movies
the best one from blade runner yeah it
was in blade runner uh it's called the
bradbury building yeah uh it was also in
double indemnity chinatown it's just
closure right no it's not they do you
know uh yeah it's no it's been in use
the entire time okay uh it's mostly just
a bunch of different offices i think
there's a museum in there okay uh
there's all kind of different stuff i
thought it was had been abandoned for a
long time no it wasn't okay it's pretty
it's it's a bunch of offices so they
were using it when they were filming
blade runner as an office i don't know
about back then does that look [ __ ]
empty it was refurbished in i mean maybe
it was abandoned for a time it was
refurbished in 1989 okay
and then they never like they let other
companies buy it like investment
companies but they only
um
they kind of only let companies buy it
that would
that would keep it no that would keep it
the way it was because it's a very
distinctive not so much the outside the
outside looks nice too but the inside
with all those wrought iron like
staircases and elevators and stuff
um they wanted somebody that was gonna
preserve the historic beauty of the
place so they said we're not going to
sell it to you unless you
you know leave it the way it is and you
know just fix it up the way in the blade
runner scene that you see it in man that
that thing is definitely empty they run
through all the damn
they run through all the rooms and it's
just empty and filled with junk
remember yeah and even though even some
of the walls were broken
had holes in them yeah i like i said i
don't know about been abandoned at that
time or owned by a studio it might have
been but it did get bought by um an
investment company in 2007
and since then there's uh
you know and there were companies in it
before that but now there's like all
kind of different offices in there like
i said i think there's a museum of
chinese art there's like a bunch of
other things in there so there so it is
in use right and i think it was in use
uh when this movie was shot as well but
yeah so yeah blade runner what did i say
double indemnity chinatown disclosure uh
which came out the same year as this
lethal weapon four uh this was in there
as well 500 days of summer this is also
a [ __ ] ton of like tv shows and a [ __ ]
ton of music videos and stuff like that
and if you see it it's it's a very very
distinctive building it's a landmark in
los angeles uh so there's that as well
so yeah this movie as i said it's on to
be and it's on hulu
if you go into it
not expecting it to be a horror movie
it's actually really entertaining i mean
how often do you get to see a werewolf
movie
with this many a-listers in it yeah with
like an oscar-winning director and all
this other stuff you don't usually get
to see that kind of thing and it's in
like beautiful beautiful locations of
the ultra rich
yeah which mansions and huge yeah
this is a it's it's a classy looking
movie
yeah it's filmed really well yeah uh
it's this is top-notch
top-notch production for eight for 94.
yeah i mean this was a high-end like a
big budget studio movie yeah about like
i said office politics and a dude like
finding his nuts uh except he's a
werewolf right you know what i mean it's
just like it is very much kind of like a
superhero origin story which they didn't
really i guess in today's parlance it's
like a lot more
yeah they didn't really have that then
and now i think people are looking back
looking at going oh i see what you're
doing there so this might have been like
a little bit ahead of its time roger
ebert when this came out he actually
compared this a little bit he actually
quite likes this movie but um he
compared it he's like it's not exactly
the same but it's kind of the same vibe
as like cronenberg's the fly
um in the sense that it's sort of like a
drama and a romance um but also like a
monster movie yeah you know what i'm
saying um so it kind of has the same but
it's not exactly the same and like i
said don't go into it expecting it to be
a horror movie because it's not um but
if you go into it thinking that it's
gonna be kind of like a rye
drama comedy
that also has a werewolf in it then i
think uh you'll enjoy it quite a bit
because it is actually quite
entertaining and uh that last act is
pretty
crazy like i said mike nichols is not an
action director and uh and i like that
james spader in his werewolf mode just
[ __ ] goes for it you know what i mean
he just like he chews up all the scenery
that that uh jack nicholson didn't shoot
yeah and it's like and it's super fun i
love it but yeah so uh go watch it or if
you've seen it if you saw it at the time
let me know what you thought about this
movie because i feel like it's one that
a lot of people don't really talk about
anymore or people kind of like forgot
about and i had kind of forgotten about
it until recently so i was glad to like
be able to watch it again weirder than i
remembered but you know it's still
really good and still really fun so
check it out and that will do it for
this movie retrospective we will see you
guys on the next one bye